morning everyone um
i'm here with my assembly team uh today
uh for the first sitting of the assembly
our uh 25 members will be signing the
role and taking their seats here for the
first time
but as i have made clear this morning we
have taken the decision not at this
stage to
support the election of a speaker
i believe that we need to send a very
clear message to the european union
and to our government
that we are serious about getting this
protocol sorted out
because of the harm it is doing
undermining political stability
damaging the agreements that have formed
the basis of the political progress made
in northern ireland harming our economy
contributing to the cost of living
crisis this matter needs to be dealt
with and whilst others
sit on their hands we are not prepared
to do that we need decisive action taken
by the government so the message we're
sending today
is that the choice is clear
if the european union is serious about
protecting the political institutions on
the belfast agreement and its successor
agreements the basis of political
progress and stability in northern
ireland
then they know what they need to do and
equally the same message is there for
our own government as well
it has been almost two and a half years
since
the parties gathered here and
reached an agreement new decade new
approach
but i'm afraid it's the same old
approach dithering and delay
talking with no action
and the government signed up to that
agreement
and all of the signatories to that
agreement
recognized the commitment that was made
to restore northern ireland's place
within the uk internal market
we want to be dealing with the issues
that matter to people whether it is the
cost of living crisis
harmed by the protocol
prices driven up by the protocol we want
to be dealing with those issues we want
to be dealing with the nhs we've got our
plan
to fix the nhs to drive down waiting
times we want to be dealing with all of
those issues
but power sharing has to operate on the
basis of consensus
consensus is a the the key principle at
the heart of the belfast agreement
and there is not unionist consent for
this protocol not a single unionist mla
elected to this assembly and taking
their seats today supports the protocol
if the situation were reversed does
anyone seriously believe that we would
have had talks and talks and talks
and nothing
resulting from those negotiations
and therefore we look to the government
now
as we have had indicated by liz trust
this week
to take the action that is necessary to
restore northern ireland's place within
the united kingdom
to reset the very delicate
constitutional balances at the heart of
the agreements
and to restore power sharing on the
basis of consensus that's where we're
coming from
i think it was colin eastwood the leader
of the sdlp who on the last occasion we
met here to elect a speaker during a
period uh when sinn fein for three long
years boycotted these institutions who
said
there is no point in electing a speaker
if you can't
establish an executive his words not
mine and that's where we are today and i
echo the words of column eastwood let's
get serious all of us
and resolve these difficulties let's get
down to that work and and let's
address the challenges in front of us
together
i'm happy to sit down with the other
parties i'm happy to work with them uh
to examine all of the issues before us
i'm happy to talk about the program for
government and about the budget but
fundamentally power sharing can only be
restored on the basis of consensus
that's where we need to get to
and i hope that in the days weeks and
months ahead we will see the decisive
action taken that is necessary to
restore
the political
system here
and to see these institutions working
properly and delivering for everyone in
northern ireland
first of all
for those people struggling with the
cost of living crisis and stopping
possible awakening and the second
question is if
you emulate down the steps but you're
not leading them into the chamber who's
going to be leading from the pvp
well of course i remain the leader of
the party we have a chief whip here at
stormont we have a strong team we will
not be lacking in leadership i can
assure you
we want to see people who are struggling
with the cost of living crisis get the
help that they need we're the only party
that has put forward a plan for that
i
note that recently the finance minister
conor murphy allocated an additional 400
million pounds to the department of
health without executive approval now i
asked the question and let's have some
honesty here from the other parties if
we can do that why can we not allocate
the 330 million pounds that the other
parties say is there to help people with
the cost of living we are ready to do it
we're ready to work with the other
parties to deliver this i want people to
get the help they need that's why
ministers remain in place and the
minister of health is in place he can
take decisions about the allocation of
resources to drive down waiting times
for vital surgery he's got an extra 400
billion pounds just given to him
to help do that so decisions are being
taken
and we want to see those decisions taken
in the interest of people in northern
ireland but fundamentally to have a
fully uh restored and functioning
executive we need decisive action on the
protocol
[Music]
[Music]
the message i'm sending is that we are a
party that will keep our word when we
stood before the electorate we made
absolutely clear in utv studios in bbc
studios that if we were elected to this
assembly we would not nominate to an
executive until there was decisive
action taken on the protocol i'm going
to keep my word unlike others who say
one thing at election time and do
something else afterwards that's not the
dup we've given our word to the people
we will hold to that word until these
issues are properly addressed and
resolved
well the ball is firmly at the foot of
the government
it is for the prime minister now to
outline what he intends to do
and as i have stated
it will not be words
that will determine how we proceed it
will be actions
i've used the term decisive action
that's what we're looking for and
i'm looking now to the government to see
what they intend to do
well at the end of the day it's not just
what the dup wants it's what northern
ireland needs and that is political
stability it is the restoration of power
sharing on the basis of consensus
it is uh
addressing the harm that is being done
to our economy
by the protocol and it is removing the
rsc border i outlined in
our
to our five-point plan and i'm sticking
to all elements of that five-point plan
and fundamental to that is dealing with
the protocol
what do you want to totally
re-negotiate well i'm very clear on that
as well dougie and we have set our seven
tests um some time ago last summer in
fact and those seven tests are the basis
on which we will judge what the
government does in relation to the
protocol and that must mean removing the
barriers to trade between northern
ireland and great britain that means the
rc border must go we must be able to
trade freely within our own country
because that's the only way to restore
article six of the active union
and to reset the constitutional balance
in northern ireland
in the way that it should and ought to
be respected